[Music]
persona 5 is one of the best JRPGs in
recent years and that's partly because
it's unlike most JRPGs you're in high
school in the prime of your youth it
would be a crime to deny yourself growth
opportunities in knowledge and guts
among other personality traits this is
why we wanted to share eight more tips
on things we wish we knew before
starting persona 5 if you find this
guide helpful give us a like and
subscribe to our YouTube channel while
you're there check out our history of
persona feature and our other persona 5
guides including our how to capture
persona video let's hit the books tip 1
make the most of your days the life of a
Japanese student is in all text books
and classes on Saturday in persona 5
there's a surprising amount of free time
when used wisely these breaks can be
spent enhancing your attributes and
tightening those bonds between you and
your friends the key is knowing what
activities enhance specific traits and
relationships here are a dozen examples
ready craft lockpicks to boost
proficiency become Takumi's clinical
trial guinea pig for more guts answer
questions correctly in class to boost
your knowledge perform well in the
batting cages to increase your
proficiency give gifts to friends to
strengthen your bonds become an inside
source for a journalist to advance your
devil Arcana work at the beef bowl joint
for more proficiency watch movies and
DVDs to boost various attributes trained
to increase your max HP and it takes a
brave student to study after school
which is why not only do you get a
knowledge boost but also extra guts try
to squeeze in as much as you can in the
day because you'll never know when a
story event unexpectedly jettisons you
into the next day on that note here's
tip to watch for day specific events as
if careful planning of your week around
dungeon time and leisurely escapades
wasn't hard enough you also have to
worry about missing special days of the
week where you can get bonus attribute
boosts
check the cafe tele on Sundays for bulk
sales on useful items using Japan's
version of QVC go to the bath house on
Monday or Thursday for an added boost of
charm if you manage to form a
relationship with Miska wakame and have
at least level 3 guts you can speak to
her on the phone at the cafe on Fridays
and Saturdays tip 3 manage your dungeon
progress you learn early on there are
deadlines for reaching the main treasure
of each Palace what persona 5 doesn't
communicate clearly is that you have a
reasonable amount of time to make
progress without feeling rushed allowing
you to take a day off here and there if
you don't take your time you can end up
far from the closest save point and out
of healing resources just remember that
you can resume your palace infiltration
at any safe room you've already visited
and there's no need to run through areas
you've previously covered if you're
unsure how much longer you have before
you reach the treasure you can always
have a powwow with your team or refer to
any maps you find that said you
shouldn't wait until the last minute to
steal the hearts of evildoers which
brings us to tip 4 reach the treasure
with 4 days left as you get close to the
heart treasure of each palace give
yourself a four day buffer from the
deadline you spend one day when you
reach the treasure another to set the
calling card and a third to steal the
heart you can't perform the last step on
the day of the deadline because the
police show up before you have a chance
to infiltrate the palace so plan ahead
but if you do fail the game puts you
back a week so you can try again tip 5
how to get a hold of hold ups are
essential in triggering negotiations
with enemies with enough persuasion you
can get them to join your motley crew
personas to trigger a holdup you need to
beat up your opponents into a weakened
state without killing them battles with
one enemy type are especially easy since
they'll be subject to the same
weaknesses tip 6 experiment with fusions
before committing persona games are
always awash in well personas given
their imaginative and endearing
character designs there's the initial
compulsion to collect them all that said
you should not treat these ethereal
sidekicks like Pokemon the fusion system
drive
this point home where you embrace life
and death by sacrificing two personas to
create a new one you should try it often
especially since these executions often
result in personas you've never seen
before
you're not giving birth to these
personas blindly as you scroll down the
list of pairs to sacrifice you can view
the resulting personas stats and their
initial set of spells take your time and
compare all this info with personas you
plan to keep having a diverse squad is
key make sure to order the personas by
level that way you're not wasting time
looking to fuse weaklings also if you
perform a networked fusion you'll
usually get much better and stronger
personas than regular future tip 7 focus
on revivals when medicine shopping by
the time you reach the second dungeon
your team is well staffed with healers
since on Morgana and your main hero can
cast daya what you are short on our
revival medicines if you don't have any
revival items when a party member gets
knocked out you'll have to wait until
the end of the encounter to heal them
provided your team survives the fight so
visit the clinic and purchase revival
items regularly tip 8 listen to Morgana
your crusty cat burgler is way more than
an adorable party member who can
transform into a getaway then he is your
de-facto guide to the world of dark
hearted palaces yes he can drone on from
time to time so it can be tempting to
block out his tips in the long run
though
it pays to listen if not for Morgana you
may not have known about the many
benefits of exploring Tokyo that said we
are an all agreement that he is awfully
bossy about your need for regular sleep
that's it for now if you'd like to share
your own tips add them to the discussion
below or come find me at twitter at
normal-mode for more on persona 5 be
sure to like this video and subscribe to
GameSpot thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]